okay let's go to our next caller from
the 404 area code caller from 404 if you
can hear me please go ahead
hey David my name is Jeff I'm from
Atlanta how're you doing good go ahead
Jeff
good I called you last week and I
actually hung up on you I was one of
those leftists who doesn't believe
Russia meddled in the election and so I
was curious we're gonna ask you a
question what evidence has been
presented that proves Russia did meddle
in election the election what evidence
has been presented that Russia meddled
in the election is that the question yes
pretty much
you know because I've been following the
story for a while and I you know asked
this you know no one seems to come up
with the solid evidence who have you
asked so far I'm curious well not me not
me personally asked but I've been seeing
this question go around the circles the
mainstream media circles several
interviews on CNN there was an interview
that reach America I had our first show
where the gentleman said there was no
evidence Diane Feinstein herself had
said well they were still waiting for
evidence everyone's back bill no but so
let's let's see if we can break a few of
these things apart so what Dianne
Feinstein said months ago is that at
that point she had not yet seen evidence
of concerted collusion between the Trump
campaign and Russia but you know that
that's a different question than whether
Russia meddled in the election right
well it's far as meddling has been
flowing seem like changing voter rolls
okay but I don't change the standard now
you've changed the standard Jeff first
you said you've seen no evidence that
Russia meddled in the election then you
quoted dianne feinstein hold on a second
Jeff then you move down hold on then you
moved on to quoting Dianne Feinstein but
you misquoted her she actually said at
that point she hadn't seen evidence of
collusion and then now you're saying
you've not seen evidence that Russia
flipped votes so what is the actual
question because these are three totally
different issues and different standards
I see what you're saying well I guess
the standard is initially
I don't I was looking for evidence that
links to the collusion that everyone
talks about okay so actually so you're
more concerned collision than about
meddling is that right well it's more of
like I'm waiting for someone to prove
that that black Vladimir Putin and
Donald Trump got together okay but now
hold on a second Jeff now this is a
totally new standard first you said you
were willing evidence of collusion so
for example if Trump jr. and a Russian
lawyer meet in Trump Tower one says
we'll give you dirt on Hillary the other
says if you do that then we'll reduce
sanctions on Russia that would have you
know I hold on a soundtrack please Jeff
hold on that would have met the standard
you put out 45 seconds ago but then 30
seconds ago you said you were waiting
for evidence of Putin and Trump
personally getting together so you've
now stated all your different standards
in this phone call no I see what you're
saying I might just I'm not conveying my
point as clearly as I'd like I'm
suffering from what limbic hijacking
right now yeah so uh basically the point
is is that yeah what is the point the
point is that I feel like those the
Russia story it made whether that was
whether they provided evidence or not I
think it's been used as a red herring ah
take away take away from the fact that
the the Democrats ignored progressives
of course their issues now we're getting
to the meat of it Jeff so listen Jeff I
want to mark this down as what I would
call sort of a microcosm of the problem
that some on the Left are having with
this Russia issue because think about
what took place in the last three
minutes Jeff and then I got to let you
go because we got to move on you forgot
called in and presented five different
standards within 2 min right as to why
you don't think there was collusion vote
influent whatever right five different
standards and then when I told you Jeff
you know you're really not making sense
you actually said the key thing which is
I actually
no matter whether there is or is not
evidence that this is meant to take
attention away from the fact that the
Democratic Party didn't listen to
progressives you have just summed up
better than I ever could have the
problem that the left is having with
this issue of Russian meddling so I I
truly can't thank you enough for
presenting this phone call to us well no
I that's that's the problem I am having
I don't tell you it as everyone else in
the Democratic circles are viewing it
right I I have see more evidence when I
go back to the primaries I see lots of
evidence of meddling on the DNC side
with the Hillary Clinton Foundation
right and no one is not talking about
that and it says the absolute hypocrisy
to me is mind blowing yeah but these
these are unrelated issues Jeff and I
think that if there's any red herring I
I think it's the one that the left
should is only trying to use this that
Democrats are only trying to use this to
take attention away from Hillary's loss
Jeff I gotta go I really appreciate the
call but Jeff has just done a true
public service to us he really has and
and I really really do appreciate him
calling in today